[Music]
May 2014 the Landsat 8 earth observation
satellite passes high above Brazil over
the Amazon jungle it captures images of
deforestation one stands out something
is keeping loggers out of this area but
what is it the image shows a curious
deliberately shaped 1,000 square mile
area of untouched forests super well
defined borders that are clearly
designated artificially somehow there's
a mystery here that needs to be
unraveled something's going on in this
forest
why has this particular patch not been
logged at all the photograph was taken
above the Rondonia region of western
brazil these are the ancestral lands of
an ancient Amazonian tribe the
indigenous people called the suruí this
is their territory and the outline of
the forested area perfectly matches
their territory
these tribes people first had contact
with the modern world in 1969 the
viruses they didn't like but there was
one thing they couldn't get enough of it
turns out that the tribal chiefs
actually a big fan of technology forget
the Flintstones
these Bronze Age geeks have blowpipes
with bluetooth they'll trade anything
for tech they still have their old
weapons and tribal survival skills but
now they're pretty good at programming
too
this tribe isn't just using bows and
arrows to protect their land
they're using smart phones the loggers
hated it when they were attacked with
bows and arrows but against these
natives turned nerds they've met their
match Mangia Percy cool okay you to be
Yvonne Z for my songs Cajun tchotchke
necesario dentro de sus cement collage
raucous pursue a subheading key some
poetry now the tribal warriors armed to
the teeth with high-tech gadgets patrol
the borders of their territory
thanks to GPS they know down to the last
inch what land is theirs are you
thankful cause you for you
episode 6 AHA Tomlin did they still hunt
like ancient warriors they look at the
birds for signs they can see from their
behavior there have been people here and
even the direction they should be
looking when they reach the spot they
find evidence of illegal logging
but the loggers have fled and who can
blame them a well-aimed
arrow is as lethal as a bullet question
officer
pay un ponticello for a legitimate Chi
form of boots Pedro say public agency